I'm the best no one's better okay so
we're gonna play a little quick okay so
the first one is 500 pizza burger okay I
like baguette or a piece that I put
pizza in a bag pizza thinking of the
call with the show singing in the shower
I need to concentrate while driving of
course
early bird night and night owl kind of
is I'm more of like a like a date I a
daytime hawk I think bitter wine Oh beer
or wine okay so I prefer wine but I
don't really even drink London I'm gonna
have to say London right now we get in
trouble by the London those men and tall
hats they're gonna scream at me every
dance move that I did in my because I am
such a good dancer yeah I'm the best no
one's better
I like your notecards
yeah I like metallic sorry go ahead
I have like a VD go ahead
mmm to make music that you would want to
hear on the radio not to make music that
other people number one celebrity crush
oh I don't know anybody who wants to
have a crush on me I'll be happy with
you know anybody um most used emoji any
girl that thinks they can handle risk
most used emoji the one the dumb smiley
face the things you do I have to choose
one and finally what's the craziest
thing that's happened to you mmm-hmm I
just didn't die I think just like the
the people that like come up to me and
meet and greets and I say the most like
insane and like the heart heartbreaking
like combination of everything things
like people just feel like they can open
up to me and that's that that really is
the most insane thing ever thank you
very much bye-bye